the number one question I get and I get
this question so much you can't imagine
how do I find my passion the good news
is passion is not something that's
handed to you it is not a lightning bolt
moment it's another nice simple
mathematical equation first of all you
need to identify your areas of Interest
everybody is interested in something and
I find the big problem is people stop
themselves because they say yeah well
the thing that I'm interested in
couldn't possibly be a business so let's
take video games back in the 80s back
when everybody thought the video games
were a joke you're ruining your brain
it's like intellectual candy kids get
off the computer go play outside
Nintendo's a joke it's ridiculous and
then we have an entire industry now
that's born up around video games that
has made Untold numbers of millionaires
I met one of the founders of Riot games
that created League of Legends they do a
billion dollars in revenue from
microtransactions of things that are not
essential to play the game the game is
totally free to play you don't need to
pay for anything imagine that for a
second you're in an industry where they
don't need to buy any anything to get
full use of your game and yet you do
over a billion dollars in Revenue
because they said I love this I like
being around games I like the
competition of it I think it's amazing
and so they have and more people now
watch Esports the finale of League of
Legends then watch the finales I think
of all major sports combined it's crazy
they feel arenas
it's absolutely Bonkers but that was
somebody who said this is something I
love it's something I want to be around
it is an area of interest and I don't
care if other people tell me that it
can't be a business it's what I want to
be around with enough ingenuity
and enough forethought into what
actually can be a business because some
things can't
you can really do something with
something that's an interest all right
so an interest you need to gain Mastery
in it during the process of gaining
Mastery you'll find out whether you
actually like that thing enough to
become great at it it is my belief
whatever it is you set out to do as a
business there should be one litmus test
you should be able to ask and
affirmatively answer the following
question do I want to know more about
this than anyone else in the world
don't get into something unless you plan
to be the best that's my piece of advice
I know that's not going to sit well with
everybody
but if you want to have the passion to
make something big to make big change
it's got to be something that you
believe in Beyond reasonable doubt it's
got to be something you've just got to
make happen
so ask yourself do I want to know more
about this than anyone else because
you're going to have to get better at it
than anyone else if you want to be
excellent and deliver on the promise
all right interest over time plus
Mastery equals passion that's how you
find your passion I'm going to teach you
the entrepreneur success formula this is
the formula it's very simple it's easy
to apply that when you actually execute
it it will change the course of your
life and your business the entrepreneur
success formula are you ready you need
to if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur combine what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
people messes up what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
in that intersection is your next great
genius amazing business idea here's what
most people do
most people just pick one
most people either pick what they love
doing
but they can't figure out how to bring
value to other people so you've got a
hobby if you love doing something it
just fills you up it's amazing but it
never brings value to other people then
you never get paid you've got a really
fulfilling Hobby and that could be great
and your hobby can be something you do
in the evenings and weekends and it
fills up your soul but you'll never turn
that into a business if you don't figure
out how to bring value to other people
so you're stuck always having to have a
job or go work for somebody else while
you're doing your hobby on the on the
weekends evenings on the side Etc so
those are the people who just Chase what
they love doing right they chase Your
Passion amazing
there's other people a lot of
entrepreneurs who just go after the
money
just try to bring value just go after
opportunity right that's the only focus
like I'll do whatever it takes I need to
be a millionaire by the time I'm X years
old I'll do whatever it takes but you
won't you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
gonna lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a magazine
or website it shows you the hottest
businesses for next year these are the
industries that will take off and you
have to get into it it's like oh wow
that's hot I'm gonna go off and do those
things if you don't absolutely love it
right this part here if you don't
actually love it what you love doing
with it brings value to other people if
you don't absolutely love it You're
Gonna Lose because you're going up
against people who do love it if it's
just a strategy for you but for other
people they love it you're gonna lose
every time you can lose every time
because while you're counting the hours
and while you're trying to figure out oh
my gosh when is this going to pay off
you're going up against people who
aren't even tracking it who get lost in
it who 12 hours later they're still
doing a thing because they love it so
much and they can't believe that where
is a time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because if they're going to make a lot
of money and they end up going broke and
it wasn't because the idea was bad the
idea could have been fantastic the
problem was you didn't love it enough
you didn't care about it enough it was
just a strategy it was just an
opportunity for you instead of being
actually something that you love so the
entrepreneur's success formula
you start with doing what you love
and then you figure out how to bring
value to other people doing it another
way I like to explain it is your heart
and your head so you make the big
decisions in life with your heart on the
small ones with your head what you work
on what you do what you're what you're
spending your time on day in day it has
to be heart driven it's got to be
something that fills you up with so much
joy but then your head needs to be part
of the equation too to say okay okay
heart that's great that you love doing
this thing but how are we going to make
money how we're going to bring value to
other people so you make the big
decisions with your heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to make
it actually practical so you're not just
daydreaming constantly in la la land
we're actually turning it into something
that can have a massive impact on the
world
the entrepreneur success formula you got
to do what you love
and figure out a way to bring value to
other people doing it
when I started making my YouTube channel
I never thought I was going to make
money I did it because I love doing I
did it because I wanted visual content
I'm a visual learner I struggled in
reading books it took me a long time
when I read a book unless it's really
short chapters and and really spaced out
well I would find myself reading five
pages of the book and then realizing I
read five pages and I have no idea what
I just read so I had to go back and read
those five pages again I would look how
long a chapter was and see oh my gosh
it's 40 pages this chapter is going to
kill me I read because I I needed to
because I wanted knowledge but it was a
really inefficient way for me to learn
I'm a visual learner I like to see
things and so I said well why hasn't
somebody made this
and I wanted to be around successful
famous entrepreneurs because I didn't
have anybody in my life who had achieved
what I wanted to achieve and so that was
the root of why I started making my my
videos and my content and before YouTube
I had my website which was similar idea
of sharing the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and what you can learn
from their success
so I did it for myself
and then figured out how can I do this
so that I can make money doing it so
that I can do this as my full-time thing
so that I can recruit a team of people
to help me do this so we've got a team
of people who are all building these
channels with me so I can create even
more impact and make even more videos
the combination LED first with what I
love doing I want to create content that
speaks to 19 year old Evan who was
struggling who doesn't know what to do
who who's making 300 bucks a month was
broke who wanted to do something big but
had very little belief in himself and
and didn't have a plan for what to do
next I still make my videos for 19 year
old Evan
and I had to figure out a way to turn it
into a profitable business so that I can
have a bigger reach and be able to do
this full-time plus and have a team to
help me do it
entrepreneur success formula what you
love doing with what brings value to
other people okay so how do we do it how
do we start to figure out that process
that's an easy formula but underneath it
let's let's dive a little deeper to give
you even more value step number one is
embrace the end most people are thinking
or most people are thinking do I do this
or do this do I do this business or do
this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your heart
centered thing that you could do all day
you probably have a couple things and
you feel like you have to pick this is
the mistake people feel like you have to
pick you don't have to pick the actual
selection is in doing both of those
things combined a lot of people have
said some amazing things of me is very
humbling I think of Ed mylett and
garyvee where garyvee called me the DJ
that likes to watch so much content and
then spin it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said that I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill is the
biggest influence of all time personal
development and I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how I'm
unique because I love consuming all of
this stuff and I love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how I'm
Different there's a lot of people who
are just sharing their message and
there's a lot of people who are also
mixing things together but there's
nobody who's really mixing things
together and sharing their own message
right so instead of looking at those two
things as different right I have to pick
I got to pick this or this like I'm
going to combine them and that's how I'm
going to be unique so think about your
different interests what do you love
doing what are what are your top two
three things that you can get lost in
and they feel completely different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
usually not to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end step number two is try to get as
close to customers as possible so it's
great to be making it's big it's great
to be creative it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos I need the videos for
myself and then I share them and it
helps other people right so I solved the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first I know there's
lots of people like you but you need to
start talking to customers you need to
start getting their feedback you need to
start seeing what they interact with and
that can help guide a lot of your future
product or service creation you need to
get out of just sitting by yourself on
your couch researching and into actually
talking to people so a quick example
from my channel
the whole top 10 rules for Success thing
came because I just made one video on
Kanye West that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do Dame Dash hey can you do
Jay-Z hey can you do Jeff Bezos hey can
you do Steve Jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea sure
why not I could do that I never thought
of it as being a whole series I just was
wanted to give a tribute to Kanye West
and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person I still
get final say we ended up having over 2
000 different requests for people to
profile I still get final say as to who
we profile
because I have to feel connected to the
message and when I'm pulling out the
content if we're doing Kanye West or
Steve Jobs is always something positive
it's always through the lens of belief
because that's what I want to put out I
don't want to put out Kanye West's
biggest attacks or insults or negativity
I want to put out negativity in the
world I could easily done top 10 top 10
Kanye West stupidest things you've ever
done I'm not interested in putting that
out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what I
love doing right what I want to put my
stake in the ground to say I made this
right this is the contribution that I'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur success formula right what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people so how to figure out what
brings value out of the people you have
to get as close to the customer as
possible understand their business
understand what they're going through
understand their mindset you solving the
problem for yourself is a good first
step and then going into okay what are
you struggling with so number one is
embrace the end number two is get as
close as possible to the customer and
then number three is solve a problem
solve a problem
as you're talking to customers
as you're talking to people who will be
using your product or your service who
will be engaging with your content as
you're talking to these people what is
the problem that they're facing
what is the struggle what is the
challenge that they're facing and then
help them accomplish it
if I apply it to myself and the YouTube
channels for context
one of the biggest challenges I think
people have is a very poor environment
you've got people in your life who keep
you where you are some people may be
telling you that you can't do things
that's the worst case scenario some
people might be cheering you on but they
can't guide you you're not inspired by
them the people around you are not
inspiring enough for you and that's why
you're stuck because the environment is
keeping you small
where if you are around higher Achievers
if you're around Tom bilyu and Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and these people
they would pull you to be better and so
that's the biggest problem that I see
the entrepreneurs that I love helping is
you know you're capable of more you've
got this big mission inside you you've
got the heart and the care and the
willingness to serve you've got
everything but you're not being pulled
forward by anybody
and so I want to try to create that
through content because you may not be
able to hang out with Tom bilio and Elon
musking Oprah Winfrey but every day on
YouTube you can hang out with Tom Elon
Musk and Oprah Winfrey from the content
that I'm going to make and create right
so that's the problem that I'm trying to
solve
and I get that because it was me who
struggled with it but also the people
that I see who I connect with who are
watching the videos they're leaving
feedback from me and I'm talking to them
and I realize you've got everything
you've got everything you you've got
everything
you're just missing that environment to
push you forward so that's the problem
that I solve what is the problem that
you solve when you can combine your
passions right step number one you're
combine in your passions
step number two is we're talking to
customers people who are going to use
potentially what we can create and then
you're understanding what their problem
is and you solve it for them
that's how we start to build a
successful business
back to the entrepreneur success formula
if you get this formula if you apply it
it's simple it's basic and it's one of
the most powerful things you can ever do
and it's the one of the biggest reasons
why entrepreneurs don't win
despite having the heart and the care
and the service you have to combine the
thing that you love doing with all your
heart with something that brings value
to other people
bring those things together and you're
on to your next successful business
career
good luck also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
always being honest with who you are
where you're at what is true for you
even if you can't say it to the outside
world always being willing to admit it
to yourself is so unbelievably powerful
um that was something that I I had this
really big crisis in my early 20s where
I realized I was telling everybody that
I wanted to be successful
but the way that I was acting was like I
just wanted to feel good about being
smart and
I didn't know enough
to be successful if I was always trying
to be the smartest person in the room
and so they came into conflict and I
remember I remember the room I was in
when that occurred to me that hey if
what you want is to just feel smart you
need to quit this company get the hell
out no judgment
if that's what you want to do
fine I don't want to live in this sort
of skitched out world anymore of where I
talked this big game all my ambition all
the things I'm gonna do but in reality I
spiral out of control the second I feel
stupid and I mean it was devastating I
believe it was days to being upset and
traumatized and thinking badly about
myself when something would occur that
made me feel dumb so anyway I would
argue for bad ideas just because they
were mine I needed to feel smart and I
realized okay hold on this is this is a
thing so no judgment be honest with
yourself and that opened the world to me
once I wasn't trying to pretend that I
was a certain way and I was just really
honest with myself about who I was at
that moment I was changeable and I was
willing to believe that but in being
honest with where you're at now you can
put together a plan of action listen and
listen well because no truer words are
ever going to be [ __ ] spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is going to
take an inhuman amount of work you're
going to have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you're going to have to
learn more than anyone has ever learned
you're gonna have to push yourself
harder than anyone has ever asked you to
push yourself before you're going to go
Way Beyond your Breaking Point you're
going to run until you vomit you're
going to study until you fall asleep
you're going to push and push and push
and then you're going to push some
[ __ ] more and when you hit the limit
you're going to push again beyond that
you're going to force yourself into an
adaptation response and why
because as Malcolm X said the future
belongs to those who prepare for it
today
so if you don't put the work in today if
you don't do the unending
back-breaking work of developing
yourself into something greater the
world is going to pass you by the people
that are going to own it are going to be
the ones that did that work and the one
promise that I can make you right now is
that somebody
somebody out there is out working
somebody right now is doing the things
that I'm saying somebody right now is
doing the work of failing and getting up
and getting better and pushing
themselves and triggering that glorious
adaptation response that makes humans
the apex predator someone right now
they're putting in that work and if you
don't the future is going to belong to
them
and as Martin Luther King Jr said if you
can't fly then run if you can't run then
walk if you can't walk then crawl but
whatever you do you have to keep moving
forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
going to slow people down it's not okay
to ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect
little of yourself and demand great
rewards the only thing that's okay is to
be in line with the way that the world
really works and if you want to be great
you've got to become capable of
greatness you've got to develop your
skill set you've got to take what you
have now and if that's crawling then
[ __ ] crawl but you drag yourself ever
forward to a vision of yourself that is
so clear and so specific that nothing
could knock you off your path because
you my friends know exactly where you're
going you're willing to pay whatever
price it takes to get there and no
matter what in anybody says no matter
how many [ __ ] hecklers come for you
no matter how many people try to throw
dirt on you try to stop you try to knock
you down no matter how many [ __ ]
people come for you at night while you
sleep you will rise and you will keep
pushing forward and you will get better
every day and no matter how many times
people chop at you knock you down knock
you off the path we will get back on you
will crawl so you can walk you will walk
till you run and then you will run until
you fly and that my friends is the only
path forward so if you want a [ __ ]
future that makes you happy if you want
a world that you're excited about get
your ass out there and earn it recently
you talked about ditching patience but I
think patience helps in the long run why
do you think ditching patients will help
this is so fascinating so patience in
the long run is the only thing that I
can tell you is guaranteed to fail there
may be some advantage to
what people are the reason that people
are telling you to have patience in the
short term because here's what anybody
trying to anybody telling you to have
patience is trying to get you to
understand one very simple thing
whatever you're trying to accomplish it
takes a very long time and so if you go
into it and you're playing this
short-term gain game chances are you're
gonna do things that are damaging to
your reputation long term
that to me is not patience that to me is
playing the long game you want to play
the long game you want to be authentic
you want to be a good person you want to
do good things for people you want to
invest in other people not because
you're being patient because patient to
me is a very passive position it's
saying look
I'm not gonna like go all out today
because at the end of the day this is
gonna take time this is a marathon it's
not a Sprint and so I need to Pace
myself that's what people hear when you
tell them to be patient I know because
I've seen it play out
thousands of times so what happens when
you tell people be patient is you're
telling them hey look this is going to
take a really long time anyway so pace
yourself
here's the reality and you're you're
gonna feel the truth of this instantly
most dreams never come true
most of the people that you know most of
the dreams that you've had for yourself
they haven't come true
why not because they're brutally
difficult the world is going to resist
you it is not going to be easy to
overcome entropy to overcome inertia
the only way that you're going to
overcome that stuff is to go all out
every day knowing that it's going to
take a long time but the only way that
that dream is going to come true even
over that long period of time is if
you're going all out every day
so literally a mantra in my life and I
can't
I cannot stress this enough this is a
Cornerstone of why I've been able to
achieve at the level that I've been able
to achieve every day everything I'm
doing I'm asking why can't it be done
faster why can't I accomplish more right
now that it's not okay to put something
off even until tonight I need to do it
right now now you need to get very good
at prioritizing because if you're trying
to do everything right now you're going
to accomplish nothing and if you're
trying to be gimmicky or do shortcuts
all of that's going to fail because none
of that is playing the long game but if
ever you're allowing yourself to slow
down because you simply are
acknowledging that this stuff takes time
I'm telling you it's never going to work
this is critical whatever it is that
you're going to do in your life if you
have any interest in doing something
extraordinary if you have any interest
in performing better than other people
if you have any interest in doing
something that will be remembered this
is the take away for you pick one thing
and do it with force and determination
the only way that you're going to be
able to push past the mountain of
obstacles that is going to try to stop
you is to have maniacal Focus to know
exactly what you want to have Clarity of
purpose to have a Crystal Clear Vision
in your mind of what you're trying to
accomplish something that you could tell
anybody in a single sense when you have
that and you stare at it all day and you
think about exactly how you're going to
make it happen and you tie your identity
to it
then you've got a chance
because then my friends when that
obstacle comes before you you will
muster the force that you need to
destroy that obstacle and this is where
this kind of aggressive language and
thinking is going to help you because
they will not go quietly
and that's the problem that a lot of
good gentle beautiful souls have
is when the time comes they don't muster
the force that's required to get what
they want and I know you know like I do
somebody who's a beautiful person who's
a good human being that we wish good
things for
but sometimes bad things happen because
they don't stand up for themselves and
as Jocko willing said
most of us aren't defeated in one
decisive battle
we're defeated one tiny seemingly
insignificant surrender at a time that
chips away at who we should really be
how important is rest and how much do
you get of it I'm trying hard at the
moment to pursue my dreams but sometimes
I feel out of balance because I lack
sleep for example alright boys and girls
I'm telling you I'm just going to be
super arrogant for a second I built a
billion dollar business without setting
an alarm
prioritize sleep
I work a lot in fact I'll take the Pepsi
challenge anybody that wants to go head
to toe with me in terms of what you get
done not just raw number of hours aimed
at a computer or whatever it is that
you're supposed to be doing and
Performing totally sub-optimally I'll
just take the Pepsi Challenge on that
I always prioritize sleep I always
prioritize my psychological optimization
so for instance if I'm working around
the clock if this happened not too long
ago I was just working so many hours and
it ended up encompassing too many things
it took more energy than they were
giving that I started to feel
um
anxious isn't in fact I started to feel
claustrophobic that's exactly how I felt
I wanted to crawl out of my own skin I
don't know how to explain it it's just
like ah it was driving me nuts and I
realized I need to chill for a minute I
need to meditate I need to take an hour
and go do something that's still moving
me towards my dreams because that's my
thing but that I really enjoy and so
maybe in those moments I go read a comic
because we're building a comic book
publishing Empire so that's part of what
I need to do anyway but reading the
comic is fun
I also need to meditate and just
literally breathe from my diaphragm so
get the sleep that you need that's super
critical you do not need to set an alarm
sleep as much as you need to and by the
way if you're doing things that are
exciting to you you're I know people
some of you are going to believe me
because I hopefully I've earned the
credibility with you up to this point
and some of you're going to call total
[ __ ] you can ask my wife I can set
an internal alarm clock in my mind only
if I'm excited about something or really
stressed out but that's all another
thing which I try hardly to do ever but
when I'm really excited about something
I can set an internal alarm clock this
morning I told myself wake up at 4 15.
what time did I wake up boys and girls
not 4 14 not 4 16 I woke up at 4 15
because that was the time that I told
myself to wake up I can usually get
within five minutes of what time I tell
myself to wake up it doesn't always work
and if I'm tired I don't give myself
that edict I tell myself to sleep as
much as I need but when I'm really
excited about something there's
something I want to get up and work on
and I'm afraid there just won't be
enough time and it's a reasonable amount
of sleep I'll say anything north of five
hours I can usually get myself to just
wake up so get to sleep prioritize
cognitive optimization because then
you're efficient an efficiency is the
name of the game so sleep sleep I am not
a guy proposing
um the you know set your alarm get up at
4am no matter what it's not me go to bed
early get your sleep meditate get in a
good peaceful calm creative state so
that you can really crush it would you
be in favor of college students or
anyone that may be considering it to
take some time off to travel and
experience as many any new things as
they can in order to find themselves so
absolutely but not to find themselves so
you create yourself you decide who you
want to become but figuring out who it
is that you want to become that is
something that requires you to encounter
a lot of things to experience a lot of
life this is Kevin Kelly's whole notion
of don't prematurely optimize I think
that some of the best advice young
people are ever going to hear is you
really want to go out and explore
discover new things so that you can find
what it is that you find interesting
then that's where the discovery process
ends in the developing process begins
then you begin to create this notion of
who you want to become and then you go
down the path of becoming that gaining
those skills developing Mastery in a
certain area but first really make sure
because you're going to give
at least a decade of your life if not
more to any one thing so making sure
that that's something that fills you up
instead of chipping away at you is
really really important and the only way
to do that is to experience a whole lot
of stuff so yeah I I have no beef with
taking that time off to go explore and
discover new things I think it's
incredibly powerful you've got two
choices in life choice one you can
become somebody else Choice two you can
become yourself now I really wish that
there was only one choice but in truth
there's not and most people choose to
try to become someone else because it's
a road map it's points in a direction
you see someone you respond to something
you admire them you want to be like them
and in that process
you've made your decision in that
process you've decided to become
somebody else you have mistaken the
finger for the Moon instead you need to
understand that being inspired by
somebody does not mean to become that
person to become that which inspires you
it is to understand fundamentally what
is it about that thing that excites you
what is it what is its essence
and when you can find its Essence then
you can find out how it would apply to
you becoming you
and as Zen she says flower does not
think about competing with the flower
next to it it just blooms and that's
really your job is to see the outside
world to see the flower next to you to
understand the amazing things that are
happening all around you all of the
incredible people and the essence of
what they have and what it is that
they've done to bring inside yourself
and find out what does that look like
when it's me not what do I look like
when I'm them and once you understand
the difference between that then you can
really begin to be something unique you
can become that thing that you were
meant to be that thing that makes you
feel alive and whole and that's it
that's the secret you're just trying to
be something not that's just inspiring
to other people but that you actually
want to wake up every day and be and
that's the thing about it I'm still
escaping you whatever you become a lie
the truth somebody else yourself
whatever it is you'll spend every day of
your life there
and as Albert Einstein said everybody's
a genius but if you judge a fish by its
ability to climb a tree it will live its
whole life believing that it's stupid
[Music]
people believe that they're done because
they're not finding their path they're
not defining Things based on what
excites them and what they want to live
with every day they're just looking to
what the outside world says is good and
I think it's incredible that there are
other people doing things that are so
extraordinary that we aspire to be like
that but you have to understand the
difference between being like someone
and trying to actually beat them we talk
of self-esteem in one of two ways either
as the sole determinant of success or as
the Ultimate Enemy most people build
their self-esteem around their
accomplishments they feel good about
themselves if they're making the most
money they're dating the hottest person
or they've built the best product they
get caught in the rat race of validating
themselves against the person who
happens to be standing next to them but
there's a fundamental flaw with this
equation because when your ego is that
attached to your success it's devastated
by your failures and what the most
successful people know is you cannot
leave your self-worth in the hands of
anyone else
the most successful people get their
pride from a different Source one that
does not fluctuate with their successes
and failures so I knew I couldn't give
up my self-esteem I couldn't accept some
weird role where I just was always the
dumb ass sitting in the corner if I
pride myself on being smart and you tell
me I'm dumb and you put up a pretty good
case for it that's going to damage my
self-esteem
my self-esteem in that situation is very
fragile if on the other hand you tell me
that I'm dumb and I build myself esteem
around being the learner
now I'm going to say thank you please
tell me in what way that I'm dumb
because you will open my eyes to
something that now I can address and I
can go learn about that thing and I will
have a new skill and I can go out and
push and execute against that skill one
of the most powerful things that you
could do is become the person that
admits that you're wrong really fast and
it's crazy how much credibility you will
earn with people simply by admitting I
was wrong like 30 seconds ago I was
fighting so hard for something I was
really fighting for my position and then
somebody says something and I realize
that's actually better imagine that the
more you try to tell me I'm dumb the
more areas that you point out that I'm
weak the more things you tell me I need
to learn about my eyes are open to
something that if true I'm gonna go down
that path and I'm going to learn how to
do that and that is absolutely critical
what are your thoughts on changing
reality with thoughts and repetitions
will this worker is it just a theory
okay so there's no doubt that the way
that the brain rewires itself is through
repetition neurons that fire together
wire together so you very much can
create reality I want to say that um
it isn't unfortunately like the Matrix
but it's so close that you might as well
think of it like that but to me that's
just a metaphor to get people to
understand that you really can influence
your your hard wiring in your own brain
and you certainly can influence the
outside world by gaining a set of skills
that allow you to go out and manipulate
it and I'll give you a super easy
example learning to build a house means
you can actually build a house and you
can manifest that and turn a tree or
concrete into a physical structure now
the Matrix to me is a simple metaphor I
don't actually believe that we're living
in a computer simulation and even if we
are I don't think that it matters but
what does matter is your entire life is
being lived by your brain now what do I
mean by that if you know a guy named
David Eagleman he wrote a book called
Incognito in the book Incognito he makes
one thing abundantly clear you live in a
virtual environment whether you realize
it or not that virtual environment is
created by the three pounds of squishy
material between your ears
think about this
your brain never touches light
your brain is encased in a bone box in
total darkness
and yet it takes photons that fall on
the eye and turns it into
electrochemical stimulus and from that
it paints this environment it fakes the
sense of depth think about this for a
second there's not some little image of
this room projected into the back of my
mind this is all being turned into
electrochemical stimulus and my brain
then manufactures this environment
there's actually a dime spot blank part
in your field of vision where each optic
nerve connects to your eyes and yet you
have no experience of it that is
completely invisible to you even though
it's massive and it's dead center in
your eyes
the reason that you don't experience it
is because your brain fills it in your
brain makes a guess as to what would be
there and your brain is so good at
guessing and so good at presenting it as
if it were real that you have no sense
it is completely seamless to you
when I heard that I remember getting the
chills and setting the book down
and saying my brain is lying to me
that rat now the question becomes if
this is all made up if the sense of
distance between you and I is completely
manufactured by my brain and it's not
real
meaning what I see of it it's real
enough and that if I walk I'll hit you
at about the point that I'm expecting to
bump into you because my brain can
create that sense of distance
but it's doing it by translating those
signals it's manufacturing this space
so if that's true and my brain fills in
the gaps does my brain also have biases
and the answer is yes
Neuroscience has gone deep into how many
different biases that we have as humans
I'll give you one because this one is
profoundly impactful
you're more likely to believe something
negative than you are something positive
now think about how that can echo
through your life each of us has to
realize that all of the beliefs that we
have in our life
our choices
the scary part about the most important
beliefs in your life is most of them are
invisible I'm going to give you a couple
questions that will highlight invisible
beliefs that you have that are
controlling your life that are exactly
why I say the Matrix has you because
depending on how you answer these
questions will determine your life and
if you don't recognize something scary
in your own answers think about the
people that you love that you want to
help and you can't and you wonder why
the answer is almost certainly related
to how they answer some of these
questions number one this comes from
Einstein he said the most important
decision
the most important decision any human
being must make
is whether or not you live in a friendly
or a hostile universe
now we could have said realization but
he didn't he said decision you have to
decide because there is no empirical
truth you don't live in either a
friendly or a hostile Universe you
decide and that perception that
Viewpoint from which you judge
everything else that happens in your
life will be colored by whether or not
you think it is a universe that is
working for you or against you and it's
a choice but most people think of their
Viewpoint as being patently real as
being just objective and true and so
they never stop to question the fact
that they actually decided that at some
point either because their parents acted
in accordance with that it was either
hostile or friendly and they just absorb
that or their friends or the people that
they work with or whatever but somewhere
along the line they came to believe
that they live in either a friendly or a
hostile universe but you could change
right now right now you could make a
different decision and if you believe
that the world is working against you
right now you could choose to believe
that it's actually working for you and
in making a fundamentally new and
different assumption
it empowers you to move forward and this
is something that I will repeat in this
talk the reason that matters is human
beings do not invest energy in things
that they don't think will yield a
result
how do I find my passion
asking how you find your passion makes
the assumption that your passion has
been lost somewhere
your passion has not been lost your
passion has never been developed
passions are created they're constructed
they're developed
and it starts with interest
one of the greatest misconceptions of
our time is that your passion is
something hidden inside of you Michael
Jordan wasn't born dreaming of slam
dunks Bill Gates first word was in
Microsoft even Elon Musk didn't start by
reaching for Mars but there is something
different about these extraordinary
Minds
isn't what they were born with
it's something they had to learn to
build Brick by Brick now once you have
that you've got to start going deep into
gaining
and it's in the process of gaining
Mastery that you're gonna find out if
that interest turns into a love then
turns into a passion people who are
passionate are willing to fight through
the boredom now they're not doing it
thinking oh my God this is so much fun
they're thinking I want to win I want to
play at the highest level and I am
willing to break myself in half and this
is the thing that I cannot get
entrepreneurs to understand if you want
to be great I promise you as Tommy said
you already have any what you need which
is the ultimate evolution approved
ability to adapt so you can change to
get great you can change to become
whatever you need to but it is the
prevailing to literally break themselves
and have to get the result that they
want your passion isn't something hidden
inside of you that's going to reveal
itself magically over a cup of coffee it
is not going to come knocking at your
door
something you have to go out and build
as Confucius said
when it's obvious that the goal cannot
be reached don't adjust the goals adjust
the action steps
that may be the single best piece of
advice you're ever going to get write
that down burn it into your Flesh Tattoo
it on your soul do whatever you need to
do to remember that once you set a goal
once you've decided in your life there
is something that you're going to make
come true don't let anything
stop you from reaching that but the
reality is as you go things are going to
get in your way there will be an
inevitable slew of obstacles coming at
you
but when it gets so hard that you
realize that the path that you're on is
simply not going to take you where you
want to go rather than give up on what
it was you said you were going to do
find a different path and in that when
you really make that the Cornerstone of
your identity that you refuse to bend or
be broken by obstacles by challenges but
instead you rise to those challenges you
go over under through them you do
whatever you have to you devise any plan
to find a way through
then your life will change once that
becomes your reaction to not change that
thing that meant so much to you that
you've dedicated your life to making it
come true that you don't change that but
rather you find another way you tap into
your creativity you find somebody that
can help you you do whatever it takes to
get on the other side of that you do
whatever it takes
to build that life that you want to see
but if your reaction is to change your
goal to make it easier to move it closer
to be less of who you could be
simply so you can check a box
you're never going to have anything
that's worth having why like if you had
to boil it down why do most people fail
got it locked
the answer is they never start
now the reason that most people never
start
is because they don't think that they're
going to get a result from their actions
and then that's going to come down to a
belief that they believe about
themselves I'm too stupid
I'm not good enough I don't have the
natural talent I wasn't born at the
right time or in the right neighborhood
my parents didn't teach me that
that's why most people fail
there's a great quote by Amelia Earhart
I'll paraphrase
the hard thing is taking the first step
everything else is just persistence
and I've always loved that quote because
it's so true it doesn't mean that you're
going to get it right it doesn't mean
that just because you start you're going
to win in fact most likely the first
thing you do you're going to fail think
about all the times that you guys tried
something and it failed or the first
time when you tried to get the business
going and it didn't work or the first
house you tried to sell and nobody went
for it the first time that you lost
money and the question is what did you
do then if you learned from it double
down figured it out focused only on the
truth
then you'll move forward you move
forward because you believe you can
learn and that's that thing hiding in
that and this is the thing when people
ask me hey my mom or my wife or my
husband whatever
they don't have that belief system they
don't have what Carol dwett calls a
growth mindset how do I get them there
the answer is you don't until they are
convinced that they can learn anything
that they put their mind to that their
energies double down into that area of
gaining skills will actually pay off
with a real world ability to do
something new
they're not going to act Kobe Bryant one
of the greatest athletes of our time
would show up on game day and if he saw
anybody else at the gym as early as him
even though he was always the first on
the court he would end up practicing
longer than that person and I had the
honor of interviewing one of those
people one time
and he said I went up and asked Kobe
Kobe we have a game in an hour like what
are you doing out here practicing so
long and Kobe said I needed you to know
that I was willing to outwork you
and in that game they ended up winning
and that lesson stuck with that guy
forever
when you're willing to put in the work
when you're willing to take control of
your environment and put yourself
through the stressors required for
adaptation you literally can become
anything
and my life is proof of that I hear
people talk about luck a lot and I know
that people think about the role that
luck plays in their life
but the reality is luck is all around
luck is ever present luck literally is
coming to you every day it's passing you
by it's happening to you right now
but the question is are you able to take
advantage of the luck
have you prepared for the luck and I
think that it comes down to we have a
misconception about what luck is we
think of luck as something as being
passive that we sit we wait we're in
some obscure place and still somehow the
luck finds us
but the reality is we're a wash and look
what we're missing is the ability to
make use of it
if you have a bunch of bullets but no
gun you really have nothing if you have
a gun but no bullets the same thing the
magic moment comes together when you
have two things that work in conjunction
and you have them both you can't have
luck without the diligence you can't
have success without the skills you've
got to spend your life preparing to
capitalize on that luck and to look at
what somebody has done to look at a
moment of success in their life and to
say that it was luck is to create a
frame of reference for you in which you
can't see how you yourself could
leverage what you have to get lucky one
thing I want to make really clear
and if you ignore everything else this
is the one where you stop and you pay
attention because this could save years
of your life
the game you're playing
is not success
the game you're playing is not money
the game you're playing is brain
chemistry
the only thing that matters in life
truly the only thing that matters in
life is what you think about yourself
when you're by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts
if in that moment you feel good about
who you are who you're becoming what
you're capable of and what you're
willing to do to make a better future
for yourself
those you care about and other people
around you
you will love your life
it is the single most pleasurable
neurochemical state is deep fulfillment
okay not happiness a bowl of ice cream
brings me a lot of happiness but it is a
very transient experience
deep and Lasting fulfillment matters and
what that comes down to is how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
the piece of advice that I always give
to somebody whether it's an entrepreneur
or somebody who wants to be the greatest
parent of all time
what is your goal
you've got to start with your goal
everything works backwards from that
Simon and I did a video that essentially
broke the internet about millennials
somebody watched it
what got Simon on the world stage is
this whole concept of why you've got to
know why you're doing what you're doing
If You're just showing up every day to
cut and dye hair to keep your lights on
you're going to have far less energy to
make it through the hard times than
somebody who is there to help transform
somebody to help make somebody their
best to help them feel their best and I
hope that you guys saw that video not
too long ago of the hairdresser that
went around and he was doing makeovers
on homeless people
right man
it was incredible it was so beautiful
the look on their face at that moment
where they see themselves for the first
time in front of the mirror and they are
seeing something totally new they're
seeing a version of themselves that they
did not know was there
and the ability to give that gift like
it is so easy to get lost in the
day-to-day grind of what you do what any
of us do
but if at the core Iving you is a deep
and unending why for what you're doing
you've got something now you've got a
chance to transcend what you're doing
and the way that happens is very
tactical has nothing to do with like
woo-woo being on there it's none of that
you're gonna have the energy that you
need to fight through people always ask
me how I generate energy we get to
decide who we are there's no objective
truth that you're going to find or
uncover You're simply the collection of
the things that you believe to be true
about yourself and once you begin to
form that opinion of who you are you'll
act in accordance with that belief you
begin to shape a vision of yourself in
your own mind and that becomes the
reality
so letting other people influence that
letting other people come in and degrade
what you think of yourself is one of the
most dangerous and damning things that
you can do because they Cloud your
ability to craft
to craft a vision of the person that you
want to become and that vision is so
hard for all of us to hold on to that we
have to protect it we have to keep other
people out of that we've got to have
intention
in creating the person that we want to
become you are all hopelessly averaged
by birth
we all are and that's the great news
because the most important thing to
understand about the human species we
are the ultimate adaptation machine
if you guys were paying attention not
too long ago they sequenced the human
genome and they realize that the human
genome has 20
000 genes and everybody they thought
that they were going to cure cancer all
the diseases age-related disease
everything type 1 type type 2 diabetes
was all going to be a thing of the past
we were going to have it figured out and
then we realized that an onion
has more genetic diversity than we do
and how could that be and so they're
literally going is this really possible
do we misunderstand something like how
is it that an onion has more genetic
diversity than we have
and somebody finally said hey maybe all
this stuff that we've been referring to
as junk DNA maybe it actually plays a
role
and then they began to realize that all
that junk DNA that was outside of those
20 000 genes we saw expressing
themselves is what is called epigenetics
now if you've ever heard of epigenetics
that's amazing you're way ahead if you
haven't heard of epigenetics let it
become one of the most important things
in your life because epigenetics
is what has made us the most dominant
species this planet has ever seen it is
the only thing that you need to know
it's what I call the only belief that
matters
the only belief that matters is that you
can learn anything
I don't need you to believe that you're
good now that doesn't matter who you are
now is totally irrelevant the only thing
I want to know who are you willing to
become and what's the price you're
willing to pay to get there and that's
what humans are designed to do if you
put us under stress
we can learn something new we can get
better what are some ways that I can
stop giving this negative feedback to
myself okay so first of all you've got
to train yourself to use the negative
thoughts that you have as a habit Loop
trigger of something positive that's the
first step to all of this so I don't
think anybody
is going to be able to get rid of the
negative voice and even if you could I
actually don't think you would want to I
think the reality is you want to use
that as your Jiu Jitsu flip to get over
to the positive way of thinking to get
into that positive habit Loop to remind
yourself that even if you're not good at
it yet you can get good at it that
you're going to learn by whatever you're
doing I don't think people really
realize we construct Our Lives we build
them from nothing we decide what our
goals are we decide in what way to move
we decide who we're going to become and
what we're going to get but it's a
decision it's a process it isn't
something that somebody hands to you and
so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact reflection of your choices and if
you want a different life you need only
make a different choice
but I know right now many of you are
thinking but I don't know what way to go
I don't know what choice to make I don't
know what it is that I want to do and as
Roy Maurice Keane said I don't believe
skill was or ever will be the result of
coaches it is a result of A Love Affair
between the child and the ball
so ask yourself what's that thing you
love and don't judge yourself if it was
something that you loved as a child that
people are telling you you couldn't
possibly make money and it's that part
of the equation that I want to break for
people I want you to understand stop
asking yourself what you can make a lot
of money at and start asking yourself
what would you enjoy what is that life
that you don't need to escape from what
is the life
that is your love what is the thing that
as a kid you did whether people wanted
you to or not what is the thing you
would sneak out at night to do because
you weren't going to be stopped from
doing it everybody has something like
that in their life some spark of
Interest may be long dormant maybe that
they've pushed aside because they think
it's stupid
or maybe they failed once and I think
they're bad at it
even though they love it that sting of
the failure has convinced them to stop
pursuing him
but at the end of the day the only thing
that matters is what gives you that
energy at the end of the day the thing
that matters is what fills you with joy
at the end of the day the only thing
that matters it's not success
and sure this hell isn't money
how do you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself it's the things that
give you energy it's what you think
about yourself it's how you react to the
hard things it's whether or not you push
through and when you push through when
you persevere when you go down the
process of taking the time to structure
your life
to build it into something that you want
it to be to build it into something that
you're proud of to become the person
that's capable of the things you want to
do that can first fall in love with
something and Do It For the Love of it
and not worry about what other people
think if you hate your life I guarantee
you the thing is that you are trapped by
what other people think you don't want
to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared
you're scared you don't know what you'll
do next
but imagine a world for a second where
all you thought about was what do you
love what do you enjoy in that moment it
doesn't matter if it changes from day to
day just what do you love what fills you
with joy what gives you that energy at
the end of the day the only thing that
we all have is right now this moment
it's what you're experiencing
loving what you do how you spend your
time
point of all of it the point of life is
that in each transient moment that
passes by doing something that fills you
with joy
nobody can give you that
build that life so go out figure out
what it is that you want to do and Brick
by Brick have the courage to build that
life people get stuck they become so
dogmatic they become so convinced that
they're right and that feeling of being
right gives them a sense of self-worth
and I'm telling you right now with
compassion because I want to see you win
valuing yourself for being right is a
trap thinking of yourself as smart is a
trap and I get it man I know how good it
feels when you're right when you had the
right idea and it goes out and it wins
that feels so good but if you can
recognize
that over time it can only paint you
into a corner because the world changes
the world is adapting the very thing
that makes humans the ultimate apex
predator
is that we adapt Charles Darwin said
it's not the strongest of the species
that survived nor the most intelligent
but rather the most adaptive to change
you've got to be willing to change
you've always got to be willing to seek
out
this confirming evidence you've got to
hunger for it you've got to want to be
proven wrong you've got to literally
invite people into your world that are
going to point out flaws in your
thinking because your thinking has
already taken you as far as it's going
to so if you want to get farther if you
want to get to that next level you've
got to stop valuing yourself for who you
are what you think how smart you are
when you're right when you're wrong all
of that is irrelevant you've got to
Value yourself entirely on your
willingness
to admit that you're wrong
you've got to Value yourself on your
willingness to learn you've got to Value
yourself for your willingness to sit
humbly at somebody's feet and seek their
wisdom
to not try to be the hero but instead to
try to be the one that collects the
knowledge
when you can flip over into that when
you can value yourself for a willingness
to stare nakedly at your own
inadequacies you'll start to make
progress in life
but no matter how far you've got no
matter how much you've won no matter how
certain you are no matter how much the
things you've done in your life have
proven to be correct as Charlie Munger
says You must force yourself to consider
arguments on the other side
you can always reject them you can
always look at it and really think about
it and say at the end of the day it's
just not correct but when you're trying
to hold on to your ideas simply because
they're your ideas or simply because
they worked in the past or simply
because you like them
you will fall into a trap of dogma and
you'll no longer be able to see fresh
ideas and move in new directions but if
you're willing to acknowledge that this
world is constantly moving it's ever
changing the only thing true about the
future always and forever is that things
change
and if your thinking doesn't change
you'll never be able to keep up so if
you want to do something extraordinary
with your life step number one
always seek out that disconfirming
evidence always look at arguments from
the other side if you're able to do that
then you'll always be able to stay ahead
of the curve and aging won't be a
problem
because you're going to stay fresh in
your mind
you become invincible when you bend and
not break and that's what this kind of
mindset will allow you to have so if you
want to win
stop thinking about how you're right and
start asking how you're wrong if you
want another amazing Grant Cardone video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there